الاكل في الفضاء كما في افلام الخيال
العلمي وفي ارض الواقع حلول مبتكره لايجاد
ايجاد وصنع هذا الطعام خارج الارض هذا
الابتكار تقدمه ناسا بالفعل شركه
ابتكرت طريقه لاعاده تدوير ثاني اكسيد
الكربون الذي يخرجه رواد الفضاء اثناء
الطيران لصنع مواد غذائيه مبنيه على
الخميره فمن هذه الخميره يمكن تكوين مشروب
من البروتين يهدف الى تغذيه رواد الفضاء
الذين يقومون بمهمات طويله الامد في
الفضاء العميق كما يمكن استخدام نفس
العمليه لانتاج بدائل اخرى مليئه
بالكاربوهيدرات لاعداد خبز ومكرونه وخبز
التورتيلا
طبعا شجع تحدي الغذاء في الفضاء العميق
الذي تراه نانسيا لانتاج البروتينات
والكربوهيدرات والدهون الصالحه للاكل من
نفس النظام
[موسيقى]